[Music]
safe and stitched up oleg holds the wad
of metal that nearly ended his life
my soldier and i were in the car the suv
came under fire and exploded behind the
car the glass flew out and wreckage flew
into the cabin the metal embedded in his
skin was so hot it burnt the hands of
the soldier putting pressure on the
wound trying to stop the bleeding for
security reasons global news is not
revealing the full names of the wounded
soldiers here nor any identifying
details about this facility
fifty-two-year-old if hen was also hit
with shrapnel that tore through his
vehicle
a fragment hit me in the side peers to
the bone but it's not a problem people
get through it the man openly detailed
their injuries the stages of care from
point of injury through to reaching a
hospital but both remain concerned for
their comrades in combat
olek a father of two gets emotional when
i ask about his recovery after a moment
he explains that he feels helpless in
the hospital bed
i'm sorry i didn't expect such a
reaction from myself because the guys
from my unit younger men and not as
experienced as me my thoughts are always
with them it's a common sentiment says
this field medic crew the soldiers
they're assigned to treat and transport
to hospital are often unwilling to
accept the gravity of their injuries
there's many shrapnel injured many
shotgun wounds but
many concussion
a few weeks after the full invasion of
ukraine by russia oleg balotsky left his
motorcycle racing career to drive an
ambulance
global news was invited to a staging
area where these volunteers were gearing
up for another rotation near the front
lines
i'm not feeling like superman every time
i scare it i every time i have
pens
every
every rotation it's an honest answer
about a terrifying war that heavily
relies on donations including these
ambulances
back at the hospital the chief sergeant
says he found solace in a visit from
some of his company
they are alive and healthy and that is
important to me both men say as soon as
they can they'll put their uniforms back
on
and return to the fight
crystal gamansen global news nipro
ukraine